well welcome everybody I'm Judy ship I'm
the chief research archivist sometimes
called the unofficial very unofficial
Yale historian but I'm also the
municipal historian for the city of New
Haven so this topic really brings
together two areas of interest of mine
and personally I have to say in the past
year or so since there's been so much
focus on learning more about the people
for whom our buildings are named it
really takes me back to my history
studies in college when I was an English
civilization major and all the scenes to
come together and an overlap when you go
back to America in the 17th century
going into the early part of the 18th
century I haven't actually given a talk
in this room before so I think we'll see
how everything fits together the title
of my talk how New Haven one Yale from
saybrook we're looking to celebrate
today of course Founders Day but there's
another anniversary that's coming up
really just in within a couple of weeks
in on October 17th we're going to be
celebrating the three hundredth of the
decision to move Yale from saybrook to
New Haven and it's very interesting to
look back to see that happening so my
first title actually of my talk was sort
of re Founders Day how Yale then not
even known as EO reinvented itself three
hundred years ago and that's really
going to be the focus of my talk today
this is john davenport every story about
Yale and New Haven begins with john
davenport he was a Puritan minister from
england he had lived for a while in
holland he was an enemy of the
archbishop and he was looking to leave
England with his fellow Puritans to
found a new
colonie a new way of life in America
that would also involve a new system of
education and he was looking to find
fellow travelers and his best friend and
fellow traveler turned out to be a man
named Theophilus eaten they were boyhood
friends in England Davenport followed
the religious life eaten the mercantile
life and he really embodies a lot of the
same characteristics that you're going
to see it in Elihu Yale and all of the
early traders who became involved in
English mercantilism and trading in the
17th century really all started with
Queen Elizabeth who was one of the first
investors in the triangle trade and in
what became the the major product of the
triangle trade slaves the buying and
selling of slaves and that is what is
affected not only Yale history but all
of the history of the English colonies
wherever they were throughout the world
now eaten ties in with Yale in a very
significant way because his wife Anne
was a widow whose name before she became
mrs. Eaton was an Yale and she was Elihu
Yale grandmother so the Yale party party
of family members mainly consisting of
an her daughter Anne who lived mainly in
Hartford and was the wife of the
governor of Connecticut and we're going
to get back to the story that there were
two colonies in Connecticut not just
Connecticut but also New Haven and an
came with two grown sons David and
Thomas and they sailed first in 1637 to
Boston they were not finding Boston the
pure unsettled place that they had hoped
in fact there was already a college
founded in Boston that was Harvard found
in 1636 the religious life was rather
disrupted there was a mint woman named
and
Jensen who was questioning the religious
life even of the Puritans and an Eton
and yelling was becoming very interested
in Anne Hutchinson all in all john
davenport thought it was time to look
for a better place to live and a
scouting party was sent around the coast
and they discovered this wonderful deep
Harbor in an area called Quinnipiac that
was the indian name and it was not too
far from New York but so far the Dutch
had left it alone leaving it to the
English who were really claiming just
about everything up and down the coast
of of America at that time so not only
did you have this wonderful deep Harbor
but beautiful land beyond it this is a
view of east rock that they would have
seen coming up into the harbor captured
later in this beautiful painting by
George Durie the famous New Haven artist
who was best known for The Courier
knives paintings that became our
Christmas cards of today and to the
westward westrock here in a painting by
Frederic Church that's at the new
britain museum and this is where the
Regicides of famous judges three judges
who survived after the king came back
into power they had been responsible for
the beheading of King Charles the first
and three of them escaped to New Haven
and took refuge at the top of that rock
and judges cave well this was a place
they wanted to go according to at least
the Puritans history there were very few
Quinnipiac Indians left maybe fifty to a
hundred of them they were friendly they
were happy to trade for goods and happy
to settle on the east shore the area
known today as Morris Cove where they
are said to have formed the first
official Indian Reservation the center
of the town was laid out in the famous
nine squares that extend from George
Street
to grove street from York Street to
state street and the main one of the
largest lots of course went to
Theophilus eatin who was elected
governor of the colony and the lower
right-hand square where you see that
would be between Church Street and State
Street the large square there Theophilus
eaten and to the right right behind him
is David Yale's allotment of about three
acres that was allotted to the father of
Elihu Yale he was the oldest of the
children of an Yale and way up at the
top it's hard to pick it out but in what
is the cow was called the college square
eventually now the old campus is a
smaller lot that belonged to Thomas
yalie the younger brother and since we
don't get many women to talk about in
all of this story I've mentioned one of
my favorite women who has sort of
squeeze down at the top of that point
that goes down toward the water the
widow Potter Beecher who was a great
great great something grandmother
Harriet Beecher Stowe she was a widow
when she came but she was a midwife so
she was one of the first professional
women in New Haven and she was so valued
that her property was maintained free of
charge because of the services that she
performed this is an artist view of what
New Haven would have looked like with
the first building of what is now center
church in the middle of the green the
minister walking toward it guard looks
like there might have been a stockade
built at that time that was briefly was
a stockade in New Haven when they feared
an Indian attack but nothing of her
nothing ever came of it so here we have
an approach to the beginnings of a
college Davenport is there he's looking
to found a college but it's hard to get
started although they have money they
don't have a lot of goods they don't
have a lot of people to support them
nonetheless from Theophilus eaten he
does get a collection of books he tries
to build up
collection of books because in those
days that was really what represented a
college was a group of learning books
that you could that you could keep in
one place and people could discuss so
here we have the birthplace of Elihu
Yale we would think it would be in New
Haven but it wasn't David Yale as I said
the elder son we don't know exactly what
transpired to make him move one of the
things was that he was not made a member
of the church in New Haven the church
was both government and state and if you
did not have a seat in the church you
were kind of left out of things this may
have been because he really was either
secretly or discussed the fact that he
his own grandfather Yale had been a
bishop in England so there were mixed
feelings perhaps on the part of the Yale
family in addition he knew that he was
going to be able to it sometime claimed
the family land in Wales to which he was
heir and perhaps there was there were
not enough young women in new haven for
him to choose from in any case Elihu
Yale moved to Boston in the 1640s
married and in 1649 Elihu Yale was born
in Boston and this plaque has been moved
a couple of times with redevelopment but
i believe is still supposed to be on
view somewhere near the Government
Center in Boston well as i said in 6th
in the early 1650s something of course
dramatically change in the politics of
england and that was that Oliver
Cromwell came to the throne that was the
Protectorate and the Puritans were in
power so they could go back to claim
lands that they were in jeopardy of
losing when the price was on their head
and the first person actually who was
called back was Edward Hopkins Edward
Hopkins was married to Elihu Yale's aunt
in and he was called back by Cromwell he
was made a commissioner of the Navy he
served in Parliament and he was a very
important man in both Connecticut where
he had been the governor in fact he was
so popular but even when it seemed that
he was permanently back living in London
he was elected governor of Connecticut
but that did not lure him back so a
number of the family went back at that
time to England remaining in New Haven
was Thomas Yale being younger he
couldn't really claim the lands of the
Yale family and Wales so he stayed to
seek his fortune in America and here we
see Edward Hopkins so we get a very
different look of some of these people
from the very plain Puritan with the
white collar to some of these
elaborately wigged or and luxuriously
dressed gentleman so shortly after David
Yale Elihu father gets to England he
does claim this state of plus gros no
it's not a castle it's a relatively
simple home but it had a lot of land
with it and they also were the sheriff
of that area as well and he grew as his
family grew David's family in England he
had an eldest son David who would be the
heir to the family estate so as was
often done in England Elihu was given an
education but not a university education
he just got a good business education
and in 1670 he was hired by the East
India Company more or less as a clerk
and the following year he was selected
in a group of 20 men to become a company
writer was the title in India the East
India Company had been established by
Queen Elizabeth in 1600 and Elihu Yale
of by the time he got to Madras which
was where the whole company was was
stationed together at that time
in Madras in India he got there in 1672
and he spent 27 years they are working
both for the company and in his own
independent business I found out that
the pictures that we see sometimes of
Englishmen Anglican colonies and India
we think of them living a very grand
life but this wasn't the case in the
16th century at least not when Ella you
first got there in Madras they were
living a very isolated life on a small
island that was practically a sandbar
known as fort st. George there were only
a group of about 30 people all together
in this colony they had very few people
to associate with and there were very
low company salaries and not too much
demands on their time because a lot of
the time was just spent in getting these
ships ready to sail to various parts of
the world to sell goods to get them back
to England and as time went on to do to
find the need and the profit in shipping
slaves and an even buying and selling
slaves so having a lot of time in their
hands he and many of the other people
began to look into businesses for
themselves and what drew Elihu Yale was
the diamond business Ben Zucker a Yale
alum has written a very good book about
Elihu Yale especially about this time
and if you go to the Peabody Museum
you'll see a permanent exhibit there on
Elihu Yale's diamond business and why
diamonds were such a big part of the
early trade in India there was
opportunity of course for skulduggery of
kinds criminal activity but most of the
books that deal with Elihu Yale at this
time seem to feel that he was as honest
as most and perhaps more honest than
most he gradually worked his way up
through the company promote getting
promoted from one job to another he was
a hard worker
and luckily he had excellent health the
health conditions were very poor in
India people died off one after the
other and as they died he did go up the
scale he various sources state that he
worked with dedication to administer the
business and to follow instructions from
London he established as madras grew a
mayor and corporation for the city he
developed land grants maintained
building programs increased security he
had to fight a famine that occurred and
epidemics and he was known for an effort
that he did to limit slavery because at
one point it was very hard for the east
india company to even find slaves they
mostly went to Madagascar in the east
coast of Africa and so it they began to
actually encroach on the Indian
population and enslave them and they
when the Indians came to Elihu he did
enforce limits on the slavery especially
children he was very protective of them
most of the terms of office lasted five
years and that was the same with Elihu
Yale he came in in 1816 87 and was
replaced in 1692 by a man named
Nathaniel higgenson who was actually a
distant kinsman of his who came from
Guilford Connecticut so what you see in
all of this is the migration back and
forth all over the world really people
who were born in England went to America
born in America went to England to get a
better job and when we think of the
perils of ocean travel it's amazing how
these people did survive I guess they
figured there were so many other perils
in life at that time that they didn't
seem to to mind anyway L who stayed on
in India for some time both to clear his
name of some charges he had brought a
younger brother Thomas Yale who worked
there for a while and apparently had had
gotten into submissive there and he was
there until 16
nine when he on his own then really
amassed a fortune but he was permitted
to sail home by the East India Company
with five tons of valuable goods we're
talking jewels encrusted beautiful
brocade silks anything that he knew that
would bring a lot of money when he got
back to England now this picture just
quickly is a story of its own it's a
controversial painting that was removed
from the corporation room in woodbridge
Hall because it has been interpreted
variously the figure on the left to some
people is representing a slave with a
slave collar other people and especially
to people that I know a new and earlier
days at Yale said that it was actually
an Indian person who was bringing him a
message if you see in the picture at the
top there's a battle being fought
outside of Fort st. George between the
French and the British in 1690 and this
is supposed to be the message that the
British have won this battle against
against the French well in 1699 then
Elihu goes home and just about the same
time things are beginning to finally
percolate up to try to start a college
as I said it was it was tried by
Davenport Charles the second came in and
not only he shut down the whole colony
of New Haven New Haven was made to join
Connecticut and the these Regicides were
harbored in New Haven much to the Kings
disappointment and so it wasn't until a
replacement Minister came along pierpont
John Pierpont who took over the church
in the late 16th century that they began
to work again on this idea of founding a
college and the founding itself isn't is
in some sort of mystery because you do
have various dates if you read one of
the first published histories of Yale
they
that a group of ministers got together
and met to pool their books in 1700 and
that's how the college was founded but
the principal founder of Yale among the
trustees was was James pierpont his wife
was mary hooker pierpont she was wife
number three he had had very bad luck
with his first two wives who lived one
wore her wedding dress to church and
caught a cold and got pneumonia and died
and the other one I believe died in
childbirth and she was the daughter of
the chief founder Thomas Hooker the
chief founder of the colony of
Connecticut their daughter Sarah
pierpont married jonathan edwards and so
you get a long line of a very well-known
descendants coming from that line he one
of james Pierpont's descendants was
Aaron Burr and also the financier john
Pierpoint aka JP Morgan so it was in
1700 were to believe these early
histories of Yale that a group of
ministers came to the residence of
Samuel Russell and Branford Connecticut
hence the name of Branford college here
to honor that founding and they came
together around a table this is a
carving that you'll see in the hall
outside each of the ten ministers of the
towns around New Haven gave a four books
list constituting a library of 40 folios
and most of these books that have
survived our on permanent display in the
by Nicki library and this is the what
the gathering of the books that survived
looked like when sterling memorial
library opened in 1930 right above there
was a special room called the 1742
library which honored that collection
that was made with the first catalog
that was published in 1742 so here you
have the meeting
now on the green in New Haven this is
the meeting house the church that also
served as the center of government and
October 1701 was a special time because
as I said New Haven had been shut down
as its own colony but in some
recognition of the importance of new
haven in 1701 New Haven was declared a
dual capital so you had two capitals in
Connecticut Hartford and New Haven and
the legislature met alternately they met
every fall in New Haven and the first
one of the very first acts passed in New
Haven as Co capital was the Act two for
permission to found a college and we all
probably have heard the quotes that were
often given that they are going to be
able to establish a college where we'll
be educated not just ministers but also
men for public office so from the very
beginning although Yale has often been
called a divinity school or theological
school to begin with it was for
employees in both church and state now
the first meeting of the trustees with
an was not in New Haven you have this
strong principled founder James pierpont
you have this heritage of having a
college in New Haven but the trustees
decide to have their first meeting in
saybrook Connecticut so why saybrook
right they seem to have had this pre
knowledge that this was the place to go
first of all was very convenient it's
where the Connecticut River comes down
to meet the sound so everyone could say
it was in fairly easy reach the town
itself was very very small and
undeveloped so there were there was
really no political nature to the town
at that point but it also did being on
the water they could be in communication
with England for any shipment of goods
back and forth now the first challenge
of the school was actually opening it
because they elected one of the
a group Abraham Pearson to be the
president he was the minister in
killingworth now Clinton and in those
days you had a contract for life when
you were a minister and his congregation
would not release him from the contract
so they actually couldn't even open the
school in saybrook they had to open it
in his house in killingworth or Clinton
and as much every year as he tried to
release himself from that contract it
wasn't it didn't happen and so the
school was there until 1707 when he died
he started in this school with one
student Jacob Hemingway in the spring of
1700 he was it's spelt like Hemingway
but without a G he became a minister in
east haven Hemingway avin you probably
know and he was related to or i should
say was a forebear of Ernest Hemingway
the writer well after 1707 a period of
time went by we're still not much was
able to be developed in saybrook certain
lands were promised to them but they
were never actually turned over most of
their classes were in sort of borrowed
homes mostly in the home of Thomas
Buckingham who was a trustee the classes
grew but they grew relatively slowly and
the classes went from well maybe 10 to
20 or so they were sometimes graduating
10 a year for a year and it only took in
those days three years to get a college
degree they did the four-year hadn't
come in until about the time they moved
into new haven queen anne's war was
going on in those early years the
General Assembly tried to encourage them
a little bit they raised their
supplement twenty five percent from 120
pounds a year and but still it was not
that helpful but suddenly in 1714 a
unique treasure arrived on the shores
thereof
saybrook when a gift of over seven
hundred volumes came from England which
included 32 books and a manuscript given
by Elihu Yale most of the books were on
theological subjects the other 3rd were
in history biography travels science
though it was a wonderful wonderful
collection of books so and it was an
amazing change from the 40 plus the
books that they had gotten from the city
of New Haven through Davenport and so on
so what was this all about the Dumber
collection and some of you have seen
some jokes that have been I think even
in the Wall Street Journal and made by
the Dean about the fact that whale could
have been dumber college but he actually
was not in the running to have a college
named after him here is Jeremiah dumber
now he was a Harvard graduate
american-born who wasn't really getting
any place in Massachusetts and he
decided to go back to go to go to
England to see if he could do better
there he was the agent for the colony of
Massachusetts and then also became the
agent for the colony of Connecticut and
in 1711 he was became a correspondent of
James pierpont in New Haven and he wrote
to Pierpont that he had heard that Elihu
Yale had sent for a relation of his from
Connecticut to make him his air because
Elihu Yale had no son and so he that was
one reason why he approached or when he
heard about Elihu Yale that he was able
to get this first donation of books from
him in 1714 but he also went to Sir
Isaac Newton Sir Richard Blackmore
Richard Steele halle this was the first
time that that new literature new
science was coming to Connecticut and
you also see here another representation
of the unpacking of the book
in a relief sculpture in the hall of the
library the person who was most
transformed by this donation of books
was Samuel Johnson he lived from 1696 to
1772 he entered Yale at the age of 14
and graduate graduated in 1714 and
became one of the most illustrious
alumni to graduate from the saybrook
campus he of course later became the
founder of Columbia and I have to say
that I was a proud resident of johnson
hall at columbia and no one has
challenged his name as far as Colombia
is concerned he was in the process of
writing an encyclopedia of philosophy in
which he was trying to attempt to put
all knowledge in one book and he was
well aware that the state of knowledge
and intellectualism in the New World was
sinking most of the older men who had
been educated in England were dying off
all they really had was Harvard William
and Mary had just been founded but it
was first of all not it was not a
congregational it was an Anglican school
and it was far away and it wasn't always
in operation now with nine of the ten
founders of Yale had been educated at
Harvard well when Johnson saw these
books and took them out he wrote in his
autobiography all this was like a flood
of day to my low state of mind that he
found himself like one emerging out of
the glimmer of Twilight into the full
sunshine of open day and in fact he
considered what he had learned at Yale
quote nothing but the scholastic cobwebs
of a few little English and Dutch
systems that would hardly now be taken
up in the street in other words he
thought it was trash and garbage what he
had learned before so he learned in the
next two years he learned enough to
completely rewrite his encyclopedia
which he completed in 1716 he never
published it but it was published many
years after his death but if it had
published it then it would have been the
first english-language encyclopedia
which was published in 1728 so meantime
as I said what was going on Elihu Yale
he had heard was looking for an heir he
had remained in India as I said until
1699 he claimed his estate and he became
known as a wide collector not only he
had what he brought back from India but
of course he sold a lot of this to buy
artworks furnishing jewels and books it
was a philanthropist a dedicated
supporter of mission active activities
of the Anglican Church to which he was a
very active member and in 1717 Yale was
elected a fellow of the royal society of
london for improving natural natural
knowledge he built a beautiful home in
Queens Square this was at the time of
course of queen anne so much was
happening in london at this time rket he
had survived also as a boy the Great
Fire of London the plague of London and
so a great revival in rebuilding was
going on at this time st. Paul's
Cathedral was being built and here you
see all of these barges and boats in the
river this is the time that handle is in
coming to London to live King George the
first comes to the throne and in fact
probably it's possible that the young
cousin first cousin once removed David
who did come to live with his uncle at
the age of 12 might have been there at
the concert and here is what supposedly
it looked like when handle was showing
his musicians floating by there on the
Thames next to King George in 1717 and
they're listening to the water music
this painting which was on display for
many years in the lnb room it's owned by
the Elizabethan club is thought to be a
portrait of Elihu Yale with his cousin
David now David at first seemed very
happy in London he was there for a
number of years from the time he was 12
in 1718 he was enrolled in pembroke
college at Cambridge University and
suddenly he heard from home that he was
appointed to be deacon of the
Congregational Church in north haven and
he just left he left London sail back
home and kind of said he would rather be
a farmer in New Haven than a rich man in
London and that was the end of his
relationship with Elihu Yale now what
became Yale College known then as just
the Collegiate School considered that to
be quite important on their behalf
because in 1724 it they wrote in their
minutes agreed that an honorary degree
be offered to mr. David Yale in this
College so they they considered his
departure of great significance in in
what Elihu Yale was able to do for them
well I was talking about the sort of the
fact that really the Collegiate School
never got going the way they wanted to
in saybrook and in 17 7 and 8 the first
year they were in saybrook they had 14
students by 13 14 they were up to 20 and
finally in the last year 1716 they were
up to 32 but there were not many people
graduating they varied from two to five
they graduated nine students in 1714 and
as I said the various donations of a
permanent place to operate really really
never happened so in October of 1715 the
legislature awarded five hundred pounds
to the collegiate school
to get them going on building a college
house and this moded several towns to
start bidding in on top of this because
they wanted to have this 500-pound
building built in their place so by the
summer of seventeen sixteen when there
was only one tutor left in saybrook
smallpox broke out and the students that
were left went to East Guilford to be
instructed by the first undergraduate
student who had graduated from Yale John
Hart and who graduated in 1703 so this
bidding war went to the point where New
Haven offered eight acres of land and
raised between 1500 pounds and 2,000
pounds depending on how they counted it
saybrook with the temporary support of
two trustees put up 1200 to 1400 pounds
and Hartford although they had had great
support from students who wanted a study
there and two trustees they were only
able to raise 700 pounds so on in
October 1716 they held a meeting in new
haven by adjournment from saybrook and
this was very symbolic because they met
in New Haven as i said in october 17th
1716 and voted to remove the collegiate
school to New Haven as quote a very
convenient place for it and for which
the most liberal donations are given and
this they were hesitant to feel that
their power was enough and so they took
it also to the governor council and
assembly and it was confirmed by them
and they appointed Samuel Johnson to
take care of the College in New Haven so
there was still in fighting going on
though the first official commencement
was held in a small way in new haven in
1717 at the same time they had a
commencement in Hartford of some of the
students who have been studying up there
with a tutor and there were also
for people that were still trying to
study in saybrook so it was a very
divided time but things did come
together and it had been confirmed so
the person really becomes important at
that time and we're about coming to the
close of this long story was Cotton
Mather Cotton Mather name usually
associated with Harvard it let it be
known that he was disillusioned with
Harvard that had passed him over for
being the next president and he decided
to turn his attentions to helping out
the school in New Haven and he wrote a
letter to as we know to Elihu Yale and
this was something that did was going to
do the trick in the meantime they had
this money and they did get started on
the building in New Haven and this is an
idea anyway of what the building looked
like it was a wooden building and it
didn't last very long remains of it
remained in use as a kitchen in 1780 but
by really by 1750 when Connecticut Hall
was built that really became the center
of Yale life Connecticut Hall of course
they only build original building still
standing so the interior remained to be
finished the exterior of the building
and they still wanted money to go ahead
to finish off the library and so on and
so Cotton Mather does right to Elihu
Yale and I wouldn't go into the whole
letter which is wonderful all of it but
the what the key sentence is when you
wrote to Lau Yale and said if what is
forming at New Haven might wear the name
of Yale College it would be better than
a name of sons and daughters and your
munificence might easily obtained for
you such a commemoration and
perpetuation of your valuable name as
would indeed be
better than an Egyptian pyramid and then
shortly before the commencement in
September of seventeen eighteen when
they were going to have the full-blown
commencement in New Haven news reached
New Haven that a ship had landed in
boston with a large box of books the
picture and arms of king george and 200
pounds sterling worth of english goods
now this actually sold for much more
than 200 pounds when it was finally sold
they thought all to the value of 800
pounds at that time eventually the goods
did sell for 500 pounds and of course
they didn't sell off the books or the
portraits so it's generally considered a
gift of roughly 500 pounds and here is
Elihu Yale as he is mostly reproduced
today and how we remember him he had
intended to that to be just a first gift
he said that he was planning to live us
a leave a substantial donation to Yale
in gratitude for having the school named
after him but he died unexpectedly at
least to him in 1721 and his letter of
intent was fought by his widow and did
not hold up in court and so except for
some additional books that he had sent
Yale did not get any more money he was
buried in wrexham in Wales where his
country estate was and wrexham Tower and
sabra College was modeled after the
tower of his church and they gave a
stone which is inscribed that is set
into the tower from the Welsh church so
even though he did not give the gift
that he hoped might be as large as
10,000 pounds his gift was the largest
private donation to the college for over
100 years and in the first published
history of Yale President Thomas clap
wrote he was a gentleman who greatly
abounded in good humor and general
city as well as in wealth and his name
and memory will be gratefully
perpetuated in Yale College so for the
first time not only do they have a name
but they finally had a real president
they had had a rector Pearson who had to
live at home do two jobs at the same
time then they had Timothy Cutler it was
the same thing he just kept staying at
his parish in milford and would only see
students occasionally usually if they
came to see him and just attended the
trustees meeting but Timothy Cutler was
appointed president and stayed in New
Haven his story and the influence of Liu
Yale is a story for another day how all
these Anglican books sent by Elihu Yale
caused not only Timothy Cutler but
Samuel Johnson and many of the ministers
around New Haven to feel that they had
never been in the true religion and they
all converted to the Anglican Church and
went to England to be ordained and
that's what Samuel Johnson founds the
Anglican College of Columbia in New York
but the saybrook story has still a
little bit more to go just at the end
and that is getting these books out of
saybrook to have what is constituting
Yale the library in New Haven and this
was easier said than done saybrook felt
that the college was to be in saybrook
it would be like sabra college and that
the books were part of that city or town
college and they belong to the town and
maybe they thought they'd find found
another college and those would be the
books that they would use so various
letters were sent back and forth trying
to get these books and finally it got to
the point where they even the trustees
went to the house in saybrook where they
were and Buckinghams son who was by then
had the books wouldn't give them up
finally the governor in December of
seventeen eighteen had to send a major
to the house and wrote a very long
letter about the riotous and tumultuous
her in which people had been treated and
that they better turn over these books
and so forth and he said that he was
sending armed guards to prevent any
riotous doings and that they better turn
those books over right away but of
course as you see in this representation
that didn't happen the saber people held
on to the books and even on the way back
it was said that they grabbed books off
the sides of the cart even destroying
them rather than having them get back to
New Haven so 260 books were not
accounted for which was a pretty large
percentage in those days and what was
the money of Elihu Yale used for it then
if the outside of the building was
finished here you have another rendition
of the building it was very long and
narrow in order to bring in as much
light into the students rooms as
possible so there's the floor plan on
the very far left you have the library
and that's where the books went when
they were finally taken away from the
town and brought back to New Haven
outside of the library as you come in
there is a carving which says the
library is the heart of the University
and that has certainly has always been
the same for Yale and the library has
shown really the growth of the
university over time so just to quickly
remind us if this there we go finally a
clap president clap put out the first
written catalog of the library called
the 1740 called 1742 was published in
1743 with he says if you follow the
arrangement of knowledge that was
written by Johnson Samuel Johnson and
use all the books that he used to base
it on you'll know everything there is to
know and the through the years the
library moved into better and better
quarters first it went into the chapel
that was built in 1760 on the left this
is the old brick row in 18
7 it moved to its own first own separate
library building in the early 1840s and
here you see the nave of the library
which is now Dwight chapel there was a
wonderful chittenden library which was
the first library built as a sort of an
attachment on the side of the old
library was the first to have a
reference room and modern library
facilities and the wonderful Tiffany
window that was made especially
personally designed by Tiffany to show
all the branches of literature then of
course the great sterling memorial
library the by Nicki among many other
special libraries that have been built
in the 20th century finally it got to a
point where the catalogs were sort of
taking over the nave but then along we
were rescued by the digital system and
this is what the library looks at today
but just to finish off the story there
was a certain type of humor I mean it
was desperation of the people of
saybrook to hold on to these books which
were really there only claim to fame and
the story has been talked about art has
been rich own about it but it was also
remembered in song called the battle of
the books and you will still find that
song in Yale song books I won't give you
all the lines but some of them are
really clever and I would like to just
end with reading some of this to you
tattlers and spectators hurled through
the blue the author was steel they felt
like it too Newton's Principia all about
gravity proved he was right in the head
made a cavity tomes on theology Hebrew
philology flew with reflections on one's
genealogy sermon and tracked full many
had wet they never cracked books but by
books they were cracked Chaucer and
Spencer dealt many a blow never did
library circulate so almost a fourth of
the volumes was taken but milton was
saved and they
brought home the bacon thank you he's
trying to get another round of applause
for two